今日はこちらしていいか分です
ビーン
うん
分の
入った
体の便9分から言葉の勉強について話ししたいんです
僕のビデオに対して興味ありましたら是非あの登録してください
この金のところでと一気すればまたその知らせ
届けることになるんですけれどもそしてウマー
私が便器に言葉を勉強しているその臨機でまたぜひ
いらしてくださいあの非常に今あの
楽しい言葉の音勉強の場ですよ
今日の話のテーマは
の英会話やめましょうというテーマですよ
書類なぜよそれを言うかっていうとねまああの日本ではですねもちろんその外国語を
勉強するときに一番その
年きまー人気でもないけれども皆さん
勉強したいああ勉強したくてもないけどん勉強しなくちゃならない言葉はも英語ですよ
その英語の中ではですねその英会話っていうのは一つのま
マーレ勉強方法でもあるし勉強の目標でもある
スロー金もある
英会話 carver しかし僕に見るはですね色んな理由でですねいい会話は無意味
なんですか
例えば後6人の日本人が
その互いに英語で話し種
本当にあの別にその人たちとは
うーん
どこに言いたいことはないわけですよだから買い物ための会話
そしてそのみんなそのまあいえば
完璧な英語じゃないわけですよねだからそれ用聞くだけではそんなに
よくならないんですよそしてみんなその使うを合意が非常に限定されています
内容が限定されている
まぁねぇ t speak がそこにスピーカーがそれのグループのいわゆるまあ
指導者というか先生というか言ってもね
大した効果はないし大して意味もない
だけども
そのいい会話が無意味だけじゃなくてそれほどその英語のその進歩に対してその
それほどまあ効果的じゃないだけじゃなくて
なぜ日本で英語しかないんですがなぜその英語を勉強しないといけないのか
日本その島国で1億3000万人が住んでるわけですよ
相撲日その英語を使う必要もないし
周りの隣の国も韓国であろうが中国であろうが
あの第1 bp まいろんな国はあるわけですよロシアとかね
あのあそこでもねそれぞれの国のあの言葉があるわけですよ
マルイは今の
21世紀ではですねインターネット r
エマーん
古牢なぁが終わったらねまた
石後期に乗ってどこへでも行けるわけですよ
じゃなんで英語だけしかまあみんな
勉強しないのかですね僕の意味ではですね
僕の考えでは
外国合弁クロス勉強する事は非常に大切だ
教育というのはそれは自分のそのそのそ立というか開発する人間としてをの
自分を素子あのあるですよ育つとか
開発ベロラップするそういう意味ではもちろん外国語を勉強する
a ことが非常にあの
意味がある
でじゃあ守備停車の外国語を勉強したことで
じゃその外国語を自分の生活の中に使うかっては相当とは限らないんですよ
しかし数学校では
いろんな科学とか数学とかいろんなものをですね勉強してそれは自分のその人間として
の教育
その人民元としてのそのまあ質というかあげる
タイ発する意味でそういういろんな
科目を勉強するわけですよそのなかの1つとしては
僕はあのもちろんあの
国語って言うのはねどんな国でもその国を国ごと
また外国語一つの外国語は勉強するのは当たり前だと思います
しかしそれが英語でないといけないということはないと思うんですよ
あの中隣の
中国語とか韓国語とか
あのーまあライアンのパラジェルのポルトガル語でもいいし
ロシア語でも何語でもいいわけですよ
そしてあの
僕の経験からすると一つの外国語を勉強したことで
自分のその頭が
その
弾力性がつく重農性があるその
いろんなたいもっとその一つのパターンしかライブ日本語だ日本語英語は英語
その一つのパターン1パターンしかない頭に比べて一つの外国語を勉強した人間の方が
頭がもっと柔軟で弾力的にな
てくるその時点で
じゃあもう一つの外国語まあいえば英語
あるいはスペイン語勉強するそういう意味ではいその条件がもっとよくなっているわけ
です
だけどもまず第一にですねその1人のそのまあ政党はね英語に興味ないとじゃあもう
どんです
どこか自分のスキーな京見ながら言葉を選んでね
じゃあその言葉を勉強してくださいそれは大人に対しても言えることです
であのまぁ僕の場合は20各国を
まあ違った程度で話せるんですけれども
勉強したがあるわけですしたことがあるんですよそれ以降
そういうことに通じてですね色んな外国語を勉強することによって違った文化
違った人たち干潟書等どう生きているか
何らの国の歴史はどうあるかいろんなその非常にその人間として知りたい
ス知るべきものが得るわけですよだから英会話女やめましょう
その強制的にも英語しかないよみましょう
外国語
勉強しましょう楽しく勉強しましょうそれからその会話てが自分でこれ話すシュアなし
すぐじゃなくて理解する
聞く読む自分のその脳を少し拡大しようとそして
あのその理解動画
その
ある程度になった時点でもちろん合意も理解料ふむ
よくなっている合意もある程度豊富になっている時点で
もう話しする機会も
出てくるだろうしその時にその自分の言いたいことを言える
も能力が開発できるわけですよしかしもう
いやでも英語そして英会話
あの
[音楽]
日本人どうしでいろんなアイナー意味のない会話するようなことは僕は意味がないと
意味のない話は意味がないとそう思いますそれじゃどうも
ご意見ぜひあの
楽しみにしていますさようなら
いいいい
うんん
5分
んうん